we're learning more tonight about the
sexual harassment allegation against new
york governor andrew cuomo
by one of his three accusers we are also
hearing the response
from cuomo's team correspondent brian
yenis has the latest from brooklyn new
york tonight
former cuomo aide charlotte bennett is
revealing new details about her sexual
harassment allegations against the
governor
in a television interview bennett says
cuomo confessed he was lonely
and asked her shocking questions about
her sex life
do you believe that he was
propositioning you yes or what
sex bennett says that made her quote
highly uncomfortable
something the governor explained away as
his own ignorance
i didn't know i was making
[Music]
her uncomfortable at the time i feel
badly that i did
bennett's lawyer says that's not true
writing my client charlotte bennett
reported his sexually harassing behavior
immediately to his chief of staff and
chief counsel
we are confident that they made him
aware of her complaint
cuomo's office says bennett's complaint
was handled in accordance
with applicable law and policy governor
have you yourself taken the sexual
harassment training required
by new york that all employers are to
give to their employees
short answer is yes democrats are asking
the public to withhold judgment
i think we are waiting for the the
investigation i think that is certainly
appropriate
others like the first female vice
president kamala harris
remain silent
just last year then presidential
candidate harris
had much more to say about four women
who had accused then-candidate joe biden
of inappropriate touching i believe them
and i respect
them being able to tell their story and
have encouraged to do it
another cuomo accuser former a lindsay
boylan says she decided back in december
to first speak out partly because cuomo
was being named as a possible pick to be
president biden's u.s
attorney general meanwhile a new
quinnipiac poll finds
55 percent of new yorkers believe the
governor
should not resign but also a majority of
new yorkers believe he should not
seek reelection in 2022 his approval
rating
has tanked 30 points since the start of
the pandemic
john excellent reporting from our brian
yenis in brooklyn tonight brian thank
you so much coming up